for founders to really be successful and
to really build
with thought and and build something
long step
which will last a long time my view is
that founders should
take the time get to a decision what
they want to build
um begin building it really get down the
line
of understanding you know really have
have it well documented of what they
want to build how they want to build it
[Music]
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders welcome
thank you very much for having me i am
honored
to have you here such a pleasure avi i
can't wait to talk to you about your
journey all the way from south africa
with startups all the way to venture
capital i am you know i'm blown away but
even just saying this
on trade capital with over 90 portfolio
companies 23 exits you've told me
but that's putting aside the eight a
fantastic initia
fantastic ventures that you've either
exited or or been successful with
yourself
avi what gives how do you how does how
do you even go
to having such a such an incredible
trajectory i have to get into the
mindset
of what you went through in your life
it's just incredible
so as a as a background um
and and it's not such a great trajectory
i i think
many people have had much greater but um
i was born in israel to
to a very average israeli family
my father was in the colonel in the air
force i used to see him once a week
and at some stage my mother had had
enough of it and
at the age of six my father took up a
role
as an engineer in in south africa and
moved us to south africa and i grew up
in south africa
um in grade 1 i met
what became a great friend and also
business partner of mine
martin and i
did my schooling in south africa studied
engineering at the university of
natal studied a computer engineering and
software engineering electrical
engineering
and to put myself through university i
really didn't know what i was doing so i
started a company writing software for
people
it was the age of arc net and ethernet
starting up and
and people were writing databases
in dbase and clipper some 87
and i started writing software for
companies and and
someone asked me what do you what do you
you need to give me an invoice what are
you going to call this company of yours
so
i didn't have anything better to do an
age of 18.
i called it great programming solutions
gps
and that's how the company started
became known by technologies
uh by the time i finished university we
had
50 or 60 employees two years later we
merged into an
ipo in south africa and then in london
and really from from
not knowing any better we had a fairly
good success
in this business i eventually left the
business
and had another two startups that are
that i wanted to try out one
we sold to walmart subsidiary in south
africa
and the second became a pretty big
property business
which i ended up being a shaleholder of
for
15 years but what i realized was that
i needed to leave south africa to if i
wanted to
make it big you know like they say
actors go to
hollywood to try and make a big well um
you know
entrepreneurs want to make a big go to
the us seems that
a couple of other people were doing the
same kind of thing um
probably much more successful with than
me elon musk
rule of puerto rico seems like they had
the same idea
so i landed in the us and i was
fortunate enough to
over the next six years be involved in a
number of startups
which were sold eventually to
uh two public companies one to a private
equity business and one
i sold back to management
where i learned a valuable lesson that
if things don't
things don't look right and don't feel
right and it's much better to
exit gracefully get your money back and
and move on
and then from there i uh um
uh went through a couple of phases went
back to south africa
got married um started one more startup
uh exited it to a public company in
india
and um and uh
my partner martin and i who who were
involved in the startup as well
decided that we'd start investing in
companies uh we had reached the right
old age of 40
and you know everyone was younger
brighter faster
you know um stronger so so we thought
that you know we have a bit of
experience and
you know if we can leverage our founder
experience to
other industries or other other startups
we could leverage that
and that was the um and that was the
birth of entre capital
wow avi i have to to focus a little bit
about this incredible entrepreneurial
experience
walk me through some of these of the of
the key similarities between the
different ventures that you formed
i think one of the most fascinating
things that i'm that i'm gaining from
from hearing these incredible stories
is really piecing together some insights
when you look back so
if you look back for example at the
first venture that you had
during college what are some key either
mistakes
or or incredible insights that you've
gained looking back at it that
you took with you throughout the rest of
your journey
sure which mistakes didn't i make
i kind of think that we were lucky and
successful despite
everything we did i love it the one
thing
the one thing is we got involved i
always started
in businesses that were moon shots or at
the forefront of what they were doing
um so we kind of were
picked the trend of you know
applications
uh databases uh on pcs
move to windows from the old novell
environment you know where networking
became
far more accessible and easier to to
manage so so we leveraged those
those things and that was kind of a
trend that followed on
um when my second venture in south
africa was icom
which did which basically took um
uh edi which was really old and you know
um and con and really wrapped it in xml
and created xml schemes
this is a 1995. or so um
again what's at the forefront of what
was happening in those days and
and sending those messages across
pharmaceutical companies and big
distributors over the internet
to in the states where we had a business
one of the businesses was called maestro
commerce where
it was really shopify in 1999
but you'll appreciate that there wasn't
it wasn't the ability to to build things
at scale in the cloud
in the in that first internet 1.0
iteration
um but having said that we did we did
very well with it
um to uh ultra dns which was a
which i was involved in a company that
was taking
uh dns and putting it in
a software stack for the first time and
taking it off
routers cisco writers and things like
that you know fast forward
15 years later
[Music]
i backed a business called ns1 out of
new york
which is kind of the new generation of
of
dns and ns1 today is probably the
leading company around the world for
application load balancing uh content
distribution
dns uh secure dns things like that
um and and kind of so
a lot of the things repeat on themselves
in in you
in you guys um mistakes
we made then kind of not understanding
how to hire
the right people and not understanding
how to scale business
um being very much um
uh probably a fair amount of arrogance
and kind of building things around
yourself
rather than building things around teams
and and
releasing um you know typical mistakes
that people make when they don't have
uh the benefit of expertise and an
ecosystem
to use and it was one of the biggest
valuable lessons i learned
moving to the states in that in south
africa you were
you were working as an island you know
there wasn't an ecosystem to teach you
how to build great tech companies and
that's the one thing that
that you have to give to israel to
london now
to boston new york san francisco
you know these places have developed
unbelievable ecosystems that
and certainly in the second iteration
post 2008
of information sharing and founders
helping each other and
just the the the plethora of information
that's out there
uh whether it's blog post uh you know
um 20 minute leadership podcast etc
for people to share information and not
be and
and not worry about sharing the
information in a way that that it lifts
up the entire industry makes everyone
successful
a hundred percent i'll be so obviously
now aside from the
from the adventures that you've had
which are incredible you've now
also invested in over 90 portfolio
companies you've seen a you know over a
quarter of them exit already
i have to gauge now you know for young
entrepreneurs as young
entrepreneur myself and for other young
entrepreneurs starting on their journey
what are some
so you mentioned about the power of the
ecosystem and power of the expertise
so here is an opportunity for me to talk
to one of the world
experts on on star formation and venture
and venture scaling
what are some key things that i should
keep in mind as i go about my venture or
or my friends you keep in mind as they
go about theirs from the early days all
the way to hiring properly and scaling
it a little bit
i know i know it's an incredible amount
to cover but but you know the key
nuggets
or the key things that that you that you
keep repeating themselves
yeah so as i really expect there's uh
you know i offer advice and sometimes
the advice is right
but um you know i keep telling people
that
uh future uh future performance uh
past past performances not indicate our
future returns
um i think that
that too many founders have
uh you know in especially in this last
year or two
too many founders um leverage their own
brand
to go out and raise incredible amounts
of money
because it's easy and my
thought on it is that for founders to
really be successful and to really build
with thought and and build something
long step
which will last a long time my view is
that founders should
take the time get to a decision what
they want to build
begin building it really get down the
line of understanding
you know really have have it well
documented of what they want to build
how they want to build it
make decisions on how they're going to
scale what those things are going to
look like
before they raise them uh you know
copious amounts of money i think they
should right
um erase their pre-seed or their seed
round
they should take time they should make
sure they have it right because
if you do things right and
if you get to this uh breakout situation
or moonshot uh trajectory you don't have
time to go back and
and do things all over you don't have
time to go back and correct the sins of
the past
so you know my recommendation is not to
not to be uh so influenced by
oh i can now you know raise the seed
round six months later i can raise the a
and you know
triple the valuation or quadruple the
valuation someone wants to give me
20 million now let's quickly take it i
think i think it has to be
um a bit of thought put into it just
because money is there money is not the
objective the objective is
how do you build a big company a
successful venture
that is meaningful to you and to your
stakeholders and
and many times funding is the uh it is
someone else's
uh solution it's not it's not the
company's best interest
um so my my view is to take it slow
repeat build the flywheel um
test retest you know and and then
uh grow um and i think it's something
it's a hard hard thing to hold yourself
back in this market where
money is so cheap but i think long term
you're best served if you do that
i think that one of the things that
you're touching upon which i've been
very curious about myself and i've been
hearing a lot here is this
this idea of intentionality not just
being intentional
about you know your team and your party
but also being intentional about about
the growth of your company and and
having some sort of coherent
rationality behind behind the decisions
you make and like you're mentioning
you know i i'm seeing an environment in
which you know there's a lot of
interest from from investors there's a
lot of interest from advisors and from
people to want to be part of different
journeys especially
in communities like let's say 8200 or
stanford but so many other communities
as well
and what i'm watching also is is almost
like you mentioning a lack of
intentionality
and and a a fight for for raising the
most amount of capital
or for the biggest names and the biggest
brands but but without thinking
perhaps too critically about how is this
going to help me reach my next milestone
of making that moonshot impact or or
some meaningful impact along the way
and so i'm definitely taking taking that
to heart but avi i i have to ask
perhaps one of the most difficult
questions you know you've done so much
you've
you've had eight incredible ventures you
have 90 portfolio companies with 23
exits you've run sigma labs you're on
the board member of monday.com from the
beginning with and so many other
companies
why work more why do you get up
still every day and work so much to
continue finding more amazing companies
and spend more time you've done it all
like seriously
so so i i would uh
beg to differ um
[Music]
my passion is uh growing
businesses growing founders and and
i live and breathe it i think a lot more
people have done far better um
it's not it's not a race not a
comparison but
if someone built nine businesses
themselves
um you know if you take a
if you if you had to compare an elon
musk he's done
you know two or three businesses he's
got spacex he's got tesla
and he's got a few other things but just
between those two things he's
he's done so much more than i could ever
hope to do
but but i suppose in my own way you know
i love founders i love building um
i enjoy the challenge
i need to be challenged every day and
and for me
it's it's uh it's it's a combination
of uh i keep telling my my founders abc
always be closing you know the challenge
that you could be missing out on
something
uh you know maybe it's a maybe a bit of
avariciousness but
but it's kind of the the need to to
learn
every day i'm i'm uh i'm first i'm
i'm insatiably thirsty for for
information and data and
of learning and and so and and also to
be fair
it's not that i've built 90 or
you know the founders have built 90
businesses i have partners
and employees who work with me and and
and the partnership has built uh 90
successes
um you know i may be the front face of
of the partnership but but everyone
in our business works really hard and
and really
does extraordinarily well and maybe i
think maybe the success has been
that that insatiability or their of
their appetite to build and not to miss
out and to
and and to help and to grow i think has
maybe rubbed off on
on on the three or four uh key people in
in in our business that that um write
the checks
right well i have to say that even
beyond the the incredible uh
trajectory i'm even more inspired by by
the humbleness that you portray here
and obviously there there are phenomenal
people that are working
on a lot of these endeavors but at the
end of the day you mentioned
you didn't find you didn't create those
90 companies yourself but you know
finding those 90 companies and then
finding the right founders and having
that joint partnership and providing
value that that both sides are both says
are happy i think that's
that's inspiring for me to say i see so
many partnerships of friends
either from the venture capital world or
or or founding partners or advisors that
that provide less value than than anyone
expected or even
have deteriorating effect and i think
that that finding the right partners
to me it seems like like growing is the
biggest
the biggest part here in creating that
venture and i think that
anybody who's been working with you is
incredibly lucky
but avi a little bit about finding the
right founders
and both founders and perhaps
co-founders so you've seen now
you know over 100 companies that you've
personally been involved with
thousands more that you've observed what
are some
interesting insights as to finding
either backing the right founders or
for a founder finding the right partners
to go on the journey with
so um partners finding the right
partners for for us is it has been a
really challenging
thing to do um i think that
we come from a a background where
all of our partners are are quite
technical
um they have very uh well-formed ideas
of
of what they believe in um they
i would say about my partners that they
all have the highest morals in ethics
um and we
to to become a partner we have to work
with someone
for a long time and we have to know them
for a long time
and and kind of that's always a
challenge to to get to the right place
um from from a founders and company
perspective we kind of created a formula
of how we look at businesses
and how we look at founders um you know
from a business perspective we call it
the four t's where we created a formula
which is timing tick um
tam and team so
the founders individually are important
but the founder is no good if they can't
work in a team
right and so when you look at when i
look to you as a founder
i equally look at your co-founders and
uh
and my test is if the founders together
can work on a team
right we don't like compromising on
um on people with uh
that don't that may not have absolute
integrity
or or you know ethics or things like
that
uh i think all too often people overlook
certain
um challenges that that founders have
because they make it up by
the idea is great or something else but
you know my view is that
you want to be partners with the people
you you're going to business with
and for for us we kind of tell our
founders that
we are founders alongside them you know
we entrepreneurs
which is very different and because we
grow up as entrepreneurs
we can't see any of our businesses in
any other way than
from an entrepreneur's eyes and so we
want to be an entrepreneur with
you um rather than a financial investor
in you yes we give you money and yes we
expect a
a great return um but
but we want to be on the journey with
you um
and so um we find that kind of that
alignment
uh works out very well and i think we've
become very quick at
identifying if you are not that um
and so we can say no quite quickly
but we also get to yes very quickly i
love that i just love avi
i have to thank you for being so
generous with your time obviously i know
i know how incredibly busy you are and
it's a
and it's phenomenal having you here
thank you for the inspiration and for
the insights
and and for making a positive impact i i
just just looking at the different
companies that either you've built or
that you've or that you've helped become
a founding you know partner
as you're saying it i think it's just
it's just remarkable and just that
impact on the world and that insatiable
curiosity that you talk about
is something that i identify with very
closely both with with
with my family but also with myself and
i think that i'm i'm getting the most
inspiration
out of that out of those two words from
this conversation but but before we
leave
i have to ask you the most important and
difficult question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
is this in terms of business or in terms
of
personal i'm gonna let you i'm gonna let
you decide that let's say if i ask
one of your one of your partners or one
of your one of the founders that you've
backed
who is avi ayal what what are some words
that they would say about you
okay then i think they would tell you um
thoughtful um
[Music]
integrity and loyalty
i love that and you and we forgot also
the two most important words in
insatiable curious uh but i think that
uh
i'm gonna start adopting that i'm just
gonna stop that
avi thank you very very much and i look
forward to keeping in touch and
it's really incredible thank you thank
you i really appreciate you
having me on the show